no I don't only wear the robe if I hate
a movie that's a common misconception or
just lounging around I was like okay
what's Wednesday's video gonna be oh wow
this right there's a Jay and Silent Bob
movie I totally forgot about it I mean I
don't want to oversell it but 20 year
old me loved doing Silent Bob strike
back so gotta talk about this it's like
it's destiny or destiny - that was much
better
[Music]
Jay and Silent Bob reboot or these is
the J and so I don't know if there's a Z
in front I lack the motivation check my
phone whatever so the Jay and Silent Bob
reboot is written and directed by Kevin
Smith it's another Jay and Silent Bob
movie another view askew movie over at
the end of Jay and Silent Bob strike
back you know God closed the book on it
and then yeah we'll have another clerks
yeah we'll have another James on the Bob
so Jay and Silent Bob strike back came
out in 2001 it was about Jay and Silent
Bob go to Hollywood to stop the Bluntman
and chronic movie from being made the
Jay and Silent Bob reboot is about Jay
and Silent Bob go to Hollywood to stop
the Jay and Silent Bob reboot from being
man yeah it's very familiar but just a
little different which is kind of what
the movies poking at that's what Kevin
Smith does well it's what I loved about
Jay and Silent Bob strike back and I
like it when he does it in here Kevin
Smith is good at jabbing at the weird
[ __ ] of Hollywood he's good at playing
in the sandbox he definitely does
operate there he's part of it but he
will jab and be like yeah but you guys
totally do that right like that would
broke down the difference between no a
reboot and a remake they're different
also Jay has a daughter played by Harley
Quinn Smith Kevin Smith's real daughter
in real life that's right the real-life
daughter of Silent Bob plays the
fictional daughter of Jay though and one
scene in this movie Jason Mewes actual
daughter is in it is it's a tangled web
Kevin Smith tangled web convoluted all
over the place sure I mean this movie
started out I felt like it started out
on a pretty solid foot and I'm talking
about the courtroom scene in that
courtroom scene I felt like some solid
comedic back-and-forth going I was like
okay we're starting out on a foot let's
see where this goes then we have a
boring second act of the movie that
finishes off really with a bunch of
references which granted Jay and Silent
Bob it's known for that it's known for
Hollywood references or so of course
it's gonna reference current movies and
fan
I just felt Jay and Silent Bob strike
back did it better might mean nostalgia
goggles I don't know I haven't revisited
those Jay and Silent Bob movies since I
saw him years ago
then when Kevin Smith goes to that
lowbrow humor I mean granted he's known
for that I just feel like I'm kind of
pestered now not twenty girl Jeremy
anymore what can I say
holy [ __ ] he said in a bathrobe Oh zero
[ __ ] Giffen don't tell anyone got a
reputation in Cape the second act of
this movie really did drag on for me the
movie wants to build up the emotional
heartstrings you know Jay found out he's
a dad so he's hanging out with his
daughter that he didn't know he had Jay
is kind of maturing throughout but in
the end it didn't always land for me and
by the end I got the feeling not just
because of the second act but that is a
part of it I got the feeling that Kevin
Smith is he really has his foot in two
generations and doesn't know where to
commit he also has a couple feet and
many hands twisted around in many
different concepts it's like he's
playing a game of Twister movie tries to
be an emotionally heavy moment and then
has lowbrow stoner humor it has humour
for people who are 30-something
40-something now who were big Jay and
Silent Bob fans back in the day also
humour for people who are stoner
teenagers right now this very second
this seems kind of all over the place he
wants to appeal to a new generation but
you cannot watch this movie without
watching Jay and Silent Bob strike back
you can probably skip out on the other
view with ski movies you won't get all
the references but you need to watch Jay
and Silent Bob strike back that's the
must though I like the concept that
Harley Quinn Smith is in this movie
Kevin Smith working with his daughter I
like the concept of fathers and
daughters and fathers and sons and
parents working with their kids and
nepotism yeah I don't know life is short
I just like the fact that they're having
fun together at their jobs together kind
of like M night Shyamalan I wasn't a
huge fan of Lady in the water then you
hear the story about how lady in the
water was a bedtime story he told his
kid and he made it to a movie and you're
like well it also props to the late
great raúl juliá who took the role of
m.bison in street fighter movie for his
kids I didn't mention that in the review
and I feel kind of bad about it I got to
mention it somewhere I mean the concept
doesn't always work for me I've seen
after Earth
[ __ ] that's the second Shyamalan
reference I made this video
Wow
I don't know what it means there may be
a Shyamalan twist coming funny enough I
uh I can't really say this is one of the
movies that works for me so when I say
by the end this movie didn't work for me
I don't know who's grown past it I don't
know if it's because I'm just not
operating on that frequency anymore I
don't know if Kevin Smith isn't and he's
trying to recapture it but doesn't
really know how to yeah he's probably
like alright I'll throw in some more
emotional moments because I've grown but
it's not really done that well it does
still feel like that person at the 20
year high school reunion who's still
wearing the Letterman's jacket you're
like ah oh man
actually now that I'm thinking about it
most anything that I enjoyed this movie
had to do with the cameos there are
three in particular one in particular
was detached from the rest of the movie
but I liked it a lot just for what it
does for one of the other view askew
movies and the best one was when Jay and
Silent Bob were in a car with two other
people to want to ruin it for you
because that's the fun of of cameos just
outside the cameos I enjoyed the movie
didn't make me laugh as often as a
comedy probably should I will say
benefit of the doubt I wasn't stoned
when I watched it maybe that's the key
cuz undeniably this movie probably would
have been a better time if I were not
sober ya know it's a party and I'd like
to set the record straight this isn't
dirty I don't need to clean it it's it's
orange you know that's how the glass is
it's vintage like 70s and [ __ ] give me a
little credit besides if I'm gonna
protect I'm gonna use the volcano anyway
so it doesn't matter
right so the Jay and Silent Bob reboot
have you seen it what did you think
about it or what's your favorite view
askew movie whatever it is whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]